I'm Michael hi I'm reading for reviewer
funk' Joseph nearing the end of
SpongeBob's journey under the sea you're
tasked with guiding a ball through a
giant Rube Goldberg machine in mermaid
man's lair
once you activate the machine you have
to match the balls painstakingly slow
speed while using SpongeBob's arsenal of
bubble abilities to make sure it doesn't
fall over it's a simple task in concept
but trying to execute it is some of the
most unfun and Sisyphean gameplay in
recent memory in one section of the
puzzle all you need to do is stand on a
button and that button opens a gate for
you to bowl a bubble into so you can
progress the only problem is that during
SpongeBob's wind-up animation for
bowling he walks forward
that means you fall off of the button
which closes the gate and prevents you
from bowling the bubble where do you
intended when you intended these kinds
of gameplay barricades are common and
forced you to restart and face your
demons again and again and again Sponge
Bob Squarepants battle for bikini bottom
rehydrated is rarely amusing or
challenging and completing it is an
entirely dry experience it looks nice
and brings back fond memories of a
classic cartoon through iconic set
pieces and tight voice acting but it's
uncomfortable and outdated mechanics
make you feel frustratingly trapped and
are ultimately outclassed by countless
other modern and classic platformers
[Music]
[Music]
spongeBob is a show built on a
rapid-fire humor in good pacing but this
game misses that mark it took me around
20 hours to play through the main story
and get a bunch of bonus collectibles
and from the movement to the jokes the
whole thing feels slow with none of the
comedic timing that makes the show so
pal of what do you want all that artwork
don't ask questions you aren't prepared
to handle the answer - it starts off
when plankton accidentally creates an
army of uncontrollable robots that you
have to defeat as a rotation of familiar
faces
spongebob squarepants patrick Star and
Sandy Cheeks your main objective is
collecting golden spatulas which are
littered around the world and are used
to unlock stages diving into the game is
exciting at the beginning the greater
Bikini Bottom area is carefully
reimagined into a clean revitalized
style that's popping with a new paintjob
in a sense battle for bikini bottom
rehydrated functions as a spongebob
museum highlighting the environments
that give life to the series there's a
keen attention to detail in recreating
the originals charm which is done well
but this underwater worlds allure falls
flat without quality of life updates
that consider how differently we play
today after the first few areas
exploring quickly becomes a chore some
spatulas are thrown at you for doing
nothing and others feel impossible to
get due to bad camera angles and
unexplained systems that you're somehow
expected to know that lack of
consideration given to the spatulas
locations is off-putting and causes the
game to start dragging within the first
few hours movement is just as unpleasant
it's a constant russell match with the
mechanics that are both restrictive and
awkward to a point that they remove your
focus from the current objective and
makes you want to put the controller
down moving platforms are slow and you
have to jump on them often if you miss
them you end up bored sitting there
looking at an idle animation for too
long while you listen to the same short
spongebob loop on repeat even if you
like Stephen Hillenburg bangers this
gets annoying fast
once you've eights of moving platforms
of weird rhythms it doesn't mean it's
over sometimes there are robots placed
right at the end of those sequences that
are too large for your character to move
around properly because of their lack of
mobility
it just feels cruel there were multiple
points in the game where I climbed up to
the top of a high structure and a rogue
robot knocked me all the way down into
the water ironically none of the
protagonists can swim so I instantly
died and respawned at a checkpoint
having to start all over is truly
deflating I'm willing to learn how to
excel with the game's controls even if
they're difficult to grasp at the start
but with battle for bikini bottom
rehydrated it isn't a matter of
understanding the controls and abilities
it's a case of the controls just not
working well it's fine for games to
punish players for being bad but this
game just feels constantly punishing for
no reason and it doesn't seem to notice
it or acknowledge it sometimes there are
different ways to get golden spatulas
but the game also randomly blocks paths
with invisible walls rendering your
attempt to get there useless and telling
you that your solution isn't right
walking into those walls feels like a
slap in the face just for thinking
creatively the levels revolve around
walking to recurring characters around
the map picking up tasks for them
fighting robots and swapping between
characters to utilize their strengths
and complete the area the loop could
work but you can't run in this game or
dodge or swap characters conveniently
you have to walk around slowly
fight almost every robot in your path
with some areas that are way too packed
with enemies and frequently move back
and forth to bus stops that are out of
the way 90% of the time for character
swaps the fleeting fun I had during this
game happened during the boss fights
[Music]
a small square guy
a huge murderous robot shaped like a
squirrel
the cutscenes before the fight start are
genuinely funny backed by an intense
synth tune and each battle is commented
live by a talking fish these moments are
a bright light in the game and make it
feel alive just for a moment it's a
delight to have the game make you laugh
at these points because most of the
other jokes in it just don't hit if you
find you stuff on feelings about the
original SpongeBob SquarePants battle
for bikini bottom
you should watch a speedrun of it or
find your old copy and dust off that ps2
this one isn't it
remasters ports and remakes are nice
because they make games more accessible
to new audiences and the ones that excel
understand that some features from the
games era are antiquated and should be
updated or removed spongebob squarepants
battle for bikini bottom rehydrated
flops like a fish out of water when it
comes to this it's a game so focused on
emulating and embellishing the original
that it doesn't know the parts of itself
that are fun and the parts that aren't
it lost sight of the basic elements that
make a collectable platformer enjoyable
this game doesn't promote curious or
keen gameplay the movement isn't smooth
and gathering collectables never feels
rewarding ultimately the game winds up
being an unpleasant nostalgia trip that
nobody should pack their bags for why
don't you move to another town that
should help out more than enough to
another town